ورجاب يبدا شكرا
لكم انا احبكم وان سعيد وافتخر ان اتقبل
دعمكم وسعيد ان نعود الى كارولين الجنوبيه
قد فزنا مرتين بارقام قياسيه هذا مكان
رائع
الرؤساء في
على عدد كبير من
المقاعد نحن موجودين هناك
ماستر شكرا جزيلا لك نحن صديقان منذ لحظه
الاولى التي
فينا فيها وقد دعمني ونتقبل هذا الدعم
وتعدت كثيرا بهذا الدعم
ايها الحاكم لقد انجزت عملا رائع عن وحققت
ان نصرا يعتبر نصر الاستثنائيه نحن
وصديقان لفتره طويله من الزمان يوافق على
ذلك هو سياسي عظيم وشخص رائع ايضا واشكر
ايضا حسناته انه رجل رائع
الله
اخرون سوف اقدمهم لكم بعد قليل اود ان
اقول الكثير من الوطنيين
هنا بمن فيهم بقي مصر السيد الاولى في
كارولينا الجنوبيه شكرا جزيلا لك على ما
قمت به بطريقه احترافيه جدا
رئيسه مجلس الشيوخ في ولايه
كارولين الجنوبيه
رئيس مجلس النواب من الرسميه سوف نتعرف
على اربع سنوات اضافيه هناك امور
كبيره حصلت همم قبل همم قلنا قبل اربعه
سنوات
ثم ثلاث سنوات ثم هناك سنتان ونصف متبقيه
ما قمنا به في هذا البلد هو اننا انجزنا
الكثير وقمنا بخفض الضرائب للمره الاولى
همم منذ فتره طويله من الزمن وكذلك ام
قمنا
بالبناء همم اقوى همم
حدود
جدا على امتداد مئات الاميال
واذا كانت الحدود الاعظم همم في التاريخ
وحاربنا المخدرات التي الان ارتفعت الى 10
اضعاف ما كانت عليه في السابق انتخابات
عام 2024 هي انتخابات
نرمي من خلالها الى انقاذ بلاد نريد مقاتل
يمكن ان يقاوم المستنقع هو كذلك وسائل
الاعلام الدوله العميقه وكذلك
التصدي ايضا
الديمقراطيين بالاسم فقط وكذلك
العولمه وكذلك الصين وهذا ما نقوم به نحن
ناقفه من اجل امريكا وهذه ما اظهره
استطلاعات الراي هناك من يحبنا ولكن هناك
من لا يحب ما يحدث في بلادنا اذا اردت في
تغيير
برمته تحتاج لرئيس يستطيع ان يقوم بذلك
ورئيس يمكن ان يفوز وهذا ما قمنا به هناك
من سائل عن الفرق بين 2020
و2016 قلت بان انا حصلنا على الملايين من
الاصوات في عام 2020 ولكن الان يجب ان
نكون
ايام الانتقادات هناك رئيس
تحدى المؤسسه في واشنطن
يعني انا اول دوله
عام مقبل سنعيد ذلك ايضا حملته هي حملتكم
غادرتم للتوا ان يوهمشه والعلاقه التي
توجد لدينا مع الوطنيين هناك امر رائع
الالاف من الاشخاص الذين جاءوا الى الموقع
يرفعون العلم الامريكي ومعا سوف نستكمل
العمل الذي لم ينتهي وهو اعاده العظمه الى
امريكا
العام المقبل سوف نوقف الغزو على حدودنا
الجنوبيه
وضع الى افضل انه ليس هناك بلد في العالم
الثالث يمكن ان يحصل له ما حصل كان
غزو واعتقد ان الرقم يمكن ان يكون 15
مليون شخص وليس او 10 ملايين وهم جاءوا من
السجون وكذلك المرافق الصحيه وهذا تسبب
بالكثير من المشكلات التي علينا ان
نعالجها ويجب ان ارحل عدد كبير من الاشخاص
بسرعه قصوه
هؤلاء هم قتله
وكذلك
مغتصبون وارهابيون ولا يمكن ان يسمح بحدوث
هؤلاء الذين يعبرون الحدود بطريقه غير
شرعيه سوف يتم اعادتهم من حيث يقدم عندما
كنا نقوم بذلك قبل سنتين ونصف ارسلنا
الالاف
يمكن ان تسليهم افراد عصابه
همم 13 عدناهم الى بلدانهم بالالاف لما
يرغبوا في همم
استقبال لهم
طرحت اسئله
بشان الاموال التي
دفعناها لهم دفعنا 750 مليون دولار ولكن
هناك ثلاثه بلدان
ربما سوف
يكونون مستعدين
استقبال لهؤلاء الاشخاص سوف يحصلون على
كافه
عناصريه عصابه امس 13
والان هم يعطونا اكثر بكثير مما اعطيناها
سوف نوقف
الاعمال العنف في المدن الامريكيه سنعيد
هؤلاء الاشخاص الى ماكنهم
نوقفوا اولئك الذين يريدون ان يغسلوا
ادمغه شبابنا وكذلك نحمي اطفالنا
نقوم بها هزيمه
عقيده
الزندر
للربه خلقه الذكر والانثى سوف لن نسمعها
بان يقوم الرجل
باخذ مكان المراه وسوف
ننقذ كرامه المراه
وهذا الامر سخيف سوف نقوم
بالتصدي لنظام الرقابه والنعيد حريه
التعبير الى مكانه عليها سوف نبحث عن
الجهات الفاعله في الدوله العميقه وسوف
نقوم بتسريحهم من مباني الحكوميه سوف نوقف
تسليح النظام نظام العداله لدينا همم
الامر كله يركز على التحقيقات
نحن
سوف نتصدى لذلك كما انهم قالوا انني ثري
جدا لكنني لم ادفع الضرائب لكننا خلقنا
الوظائف وهذا ادى الى الاستفاده الكثير من
ذلك يجب تحفيز الاشخاص وهم يسلبون
الامريكيين هذه الحوافز